today on the matt well show a prominent
abortionist declares that unborn babies
are
zombies yes they're zombies we'll talk
about that plus five headlines including
cnn pushing for more censorship of
conservative opinions
blm gets a nobel peace prize nomination
and the lincoln project tries to
distance itself
from one of its founders and in our
daily cancellation today i must cancel
shoes all shoes are cancelled i'll
explain why i have a good reason
all of that and much more today on the
matte wall show
before we get going today you know one
of the the greatest win-wins that you
can get
is when you're able to support a company
that provides you a valuable service
but also supports your values so you're
supporting them they're supporting you
and it's a win-win across the board and
that's of course you know i'm already
talking about
charity mobile um one of our most loyal
sponsors good friends of the show
the pro-life phone company five percent
of your monthly plan price goes to the
pro-life
pro family charity of your choice and
what you're able to do is help to build
a culture of life in america while
supporting a pro-life phone company at
the same time
and so that's the that's the charity
part of it um
and that's great but then also it's just
a good service
so you don't have to sacrifice good
service in order to do a good deed
you can have both that's why i call it a
win-win you get new activations uh if
you have
new activations and eligible accounts
get a free cell phone with free
activation and free shipping so you get
that free cell phone out of it there's
no contracts there's no termination fees
there's no risk with a 30 day guarantee
so what i would recommend is
listen um they're not they're not going
to
get you stuck in a contract you don't
want to be in it in so you might as well
try them out try the service out and
i guarantee you're going to love it they
also have live customer service based in
the usa
free usage usage alerts you get an app
to monitor your usage pay your bills and
much more makes it very convenient
and nationwide service on america's
largest and most reliable 4g lte network
all of that while at the same time again
you are
turning everyday living into effortless
giving
for the charity of your choice you just
can't beat it so call us at
1-877-47 or chat with them online
at charitymobile.com so you know it's
easy sometimes to
fall into the trap of thinking that
there's no clear right or wrong side in
our present culture where everyone is
equal parts
right and wrong or everyone's just wrong
flat out you know you might think and
you hear this a lot from from people
it's kind of nihilistic way of thinking
about it
uh nihilism disguised as as nuanced well
i think everybody is
everyone is equally wrong in all ways
what may lead you to this conclusion
is the simple fact that all of the
individual people on every side of every
issue are flawed
often deeply flawed prone to hypocrisy
self-contradiction stupidity
and there's so much of all that stuff to
go around hypocrisy self-contradiction
stupidity
that um you may be tempted to sort of
throw up your hands and say well forget
it doesn't matter
there's no difference between the two
sides the fight is over nothing
i don't care anymore it's easy to make
this mistake
but it's still a mistake and it's
helpful to remind yourself
sometimes that there is a bad side and a
good side here
it's not simplistic to put it that way
which brings us to
jennifer gunter she's a prominent
abortion proponent
and abortionist um so following the the
saga here
following the discussion gunter on
saturday um
over twitter first challenged gop house
minority leader kevin mccarthy to a
quote public
factual discussion on abortion now
another user not mccarthy someone else
on twitter responded
with more respect and civility than this
person deserves in my opinion
and that that twitter user said as long
as the discussion begins with accepting
that an implanted embryo is a living
human organism
as a doctor you can confirm this
mccarthy's background is in business
so try senator sass or marco rubio who
have background in law and can explain
that a living human organism is a person
now gunter shot back to this random
twitter user
and said an embryo isn't a human
it's a human embryo and don't effing
tell me what i know as a doctor
now stop there for a second an
embryo isn't a human it's a human embryo
well that makes no sense
that of course is like me saying that
middle aged women like gunter
aren't human they're human middle-aged
women
it makes no sense at all if you're a
middle-aged woman
you are in a phase of human development
if you're a middle-aged man
same if you're an elderly person if
you're a teenager
it's a it's a stage a phase of human
development if you're a quote fetus
you're also in a stage of human
development
and the thing about being in a stage of
human development is that you must be
first a human in order to be in that
stage
there has never been a tree or cow or an
earthworm
that is a human embryo or a middle-aged
woman because you need first to be human
to be any of those other things
anyway gunter continued on twitter this
time responding to someone who addressed
her by just her last name
god forbid and she said it's
dr gunter to you we're discussing the
subject of my expertise
then she says the unborn are zombies
that doesn't apply here use medical
terms or at least grown up words
an embryo is a human embryo it's not a
human
medical words medical terms zombie
apparently is a medical term
and children at their youngest ages are
zombies
this comment if it reminds you of
anything it's a bit reminiscent of
another abortionist leah torres who a
little while ago i think a couple years
ago
responded to someone asking her if the
sound of her victims keeps her up at
night
and she responded to that by saying you
know the fetus can't scream right i
transect the cord first so there's
really no opportunity
if they're even far enough along to have
a larynx
now this is what you get from one side
and
these are not extreme or outlier cases
i'm not pulling the most extreme
pro-abortion rhetoric and say well this
is representative of the entire
side no this this what's being expressed
here is the the necessary result
of the dehumanizing of children in their
earliest stages of development
if it sounds nasty and cruel and awful
it's because
dehumanization is a nasty cruel awful
business
in our culture it's cloaked in euphemism
and described in sanitary clinical terms
but the reality is that a group of
people are being excluded from the human
category
and throughout human history there have
always been people
doing this you know people trying to
exclude other people
from the people club there have always
been people throughout history who point
over there and say
those people aren't people
we still have not graduated beyond that
this mentality has just migrated to
different
areas and different sorts of people but
still it exists
and the attempt to do this to dehumanize
to
de-person entire groups of of of persons
is always evil and the results are
always horrifying and always bloody
and the people doing it are always on
the wrong side
this all becomes more obvious when
people like quote unquote dr
gunter here make the mistake of being
more momentarily honest
unborn babies aren't zombies obviously
but she's honest
in that she's revealing what she has to
tell herself
in order to justify what she believes
and what she has done
this is what she has to whisper to
herself at night in order to sleep
and i think it's helpfully clarifying
for the rest of us to hear
people like gunter say this out loud
and that's why i return to this issue
abortion as often as i do first of all
because
it's the greatest moral crisis of our
time millions of innocent people are
being slaughtered i think it's a pretty
good reason to discuss the issue
frequently i would think
also though because because because of
that clarification that it that it
offers
that this this this cuts through the fog
it parts the clouds
and it makes it clear where you stand
if you stand on the side where unborn
babies are zombies
who can be put down and discarded you're
the bad guy
you are the bad guy in this whole
drama there is no moral equivalence
whatever criticisms you can make of the
people on the other side of that divide
and there are plenty of valid criticisms
the fact remains
that they want babies to live and you
want them treated as sub-human trash
it's funny to me when pro-abortion
people use pro-birth
as a pejorative you hear this all the
time
that's another clarifying thing they
accuse pro-lifers of being merely
pro-birth i i always hear this
oh you're just pro-birth well
am i supposed to recoil at that label
because i don't
pro-birth well sure yeah i'm pro-birth i
will i will
happily admit that i am pro-birth
i am in favor of babies being born
once the baby is conceived yes i i want
him to be born
that's every every baby that is right
now in the womb of
a mother i want all those babies to be
born i am pro-birth
you if you're on the other side you are
pro-dismemberment
i i feel comfortable with where i am
and though i can't defend everything
that everyone on my side says or
believes
and i could personally do without some
of the kooky conspiracy stuff that folks
on the right seem attracted to
more than i wish they were the fact is
that we are fighting
to protect the most vulnerable and the
other side
wants to kill the most vulnerable this
is
literally life versus death right verse
wrong
good verse bad there is no gray area
at least where it matters most let's get
now to our five headlines
it's kind of kind of exciting i just saw
um i just saw
you know i you know i tic talk you know
as you know i'm a huge fan of tick tock
and uh apparently on tick tock the new
thing now with
beauty influencers they've got this new
trend
which by the way um i don't know how one
becomes a beauty a beauty and style
influencer
i don't know how you apply for that job
and i i do i do sort of hate that we we
live in a country
where influencer is not only a word now
but actually an occupation
i mean you know there have always been
people who were influencing in various
areas like there have always been
people who influence style right and our
conceptions of beauty but usually in the
past
you had to do something else like you
were an actor or something
and as part of that people liked your
style and so you were
sort of a trendsetter but now you can
just you don't have to do anything else
all you do is influence
that's your whole job to just influence
not to any particular end or you don't
do anything you just you just influence
um but in any case the influencers now
the the new style apparently uh
is they um is uh some of the women
they're
putting black like circles under their
eyes to make themselves look tired
this is i'm not making this up this is a
trend now to intentionally make yourself
to have
bags under your eyes as a trend which
means
that for the first time in my life i am
fashion forward
as a parent of young all parents of
young children we this this is our one
and only time
we are ahead of the curve with fashion
it is fashionable now to look tired
as i always do especially today
of all days because my uh our
one-year-old was up every 30 minutes
last night crying so
this is i am i this is a very
fashionable day for me
all right number one brian stelter on
cnn
defended efforts to shut down
conservative content
uh efforts being made even by by cnn
using a pithy little phrase
that you could tell he's very proud of
where he says it's about it's about
freedom of reach
not freedom of speech i want to play
this for you because
i it may surprise you to learn i
actually agree with
some of what he's saying and i'll
explain why but let's listen first
but while some cry cancel culture let me
suggest a different way to think about
this
a harm reduction model
most people want clean air and blue
skies
and accurate news and rational views and
then in that healthy environment that
looks beautiful
then we can have great fights about
taxes and regulation and health care and
all the rest
the vast majority of people can agree
that disinformation about
let's say the pandemic is unhealthy it's
harmful
so how can that harm be reduced well big
tech platforms say they are removing
lies about vaccines and stamping out
stop the steel bs
and queueing on content now do these
private companies have too much power
sure
many people would say yes of course they
do but reducing a liar's reach
is not the same as censoring freedom of
speech freedom of speech is different
than freedom of
reach and algorithmic reach is part of
the problem
okay the only thing i agree with in
there
is that it's not about freedom of speech
uh or or at least
we shouldn't be framing it that way i i
am increasingly convinced
that it's a mistake to frame all of this
stuff we would you know
everything we always try to bring
everything down in this in
with the way debates work in our country
now everything always comes down to
is freedom of spree speech the
constitution the bill of rights we
always try to boil it down to that
but i think that's a mistake
partly because freedom of speech as a
concept
is so vague nobody really knows what it
means we there's there's no agreement
when you go around say oh this is
freedom of speech
and you say that you know if you're in a
room of people and uh and
you're talking to 20 different people
and you say freedom of speech all 20 of
them will have 20 different ideas of
what freedom of speech even means
it's just it's just it's not a helpful
way of of framing
your argument so when it comes to
conservatives being kicked off big tech
platforms
uh canceled censored whatever phrase you
want to use
i obviously am 100 against it and i'm in
favor of
of forcing these some some transparency
with these big tech companies
um preventing them
through government force from
censoring in the way that they are but i
don't think we frame it as freedom of
speech
i think this is an issue of ethics
this is an issue of transparency um
of consistency of power
you know how much power should these
companies actually have
i think that's the way that's the way we
should frame this
that should be good enough is it ethical
for these companies to be doing this
that have so much power to control the
national
dialogue and decide who can be heard and
who can't
is it ethical is it right
for them while not even admitting by the
way what they're doing
not being transparent about it
is it ethical for them to you know kick
conservatives off apply a standard to
certain political ideologies that they
don't apply to others no it's not
ethical it's not right
they shouldn't have that power and i
think i can make that argument without
saying anything about freedom of speech
it's just not right and it's not ethical
and i'll use a stelter's phrase there
it's it's harm
harm reduction well he wants to reduce
harm by reducing the visibility of
conservatives that's his idea of
reducing harm
because he's worried that people are
harmed by opposing ideas
he only wants people to hear his ideas
and the ideas of people he agrees with
and if you hear any other ideas then
you're being harmed
so he's trying to you know he's trying
to protect you
very nicely by making sure you don't
hear any other ideas that might be
confusing and scary to you
i i have a different idea of harm
reduction how do we reduce
the harm being done by big tech
companies with all the power they wield
to manipulate uh the public discussion
and debate
how do we reduce that harm
i think we could do all of this without
muddying the waters
by by making it an argument about free
speech because once you do that then
first it's a
first we have to discuss about what free
speech even means and who does it apply
to and does it only apply where the
government is concerned
i mean is it as long as the government
itself as as a governmental body
is not preventing people from saying
things is it the case that free speech
is irrelevant to that
you know we could put all that to the
side
and just establish that the big tech
companies are doing great harm
to the country they're they're
exercising
a level of power that they should not
have
they're not being transparent and
they're being unethical
it's a pretty good case you can make
just based on that
all right let's go to uh number two here
from people magazine says black lives
matter
has been nominated for this year's nobel
peace prize black lives matter
uh on friday it was announced that the
organization was nominated by norwegian
parliament member
peter eddy or i think it's peter peter
p-e-t-t-e-r petter
anyway um he's told the usa today that
uh to carry forward a movement of racial
justice and to spread that to other
countries
is very very important black lives
matter is the strongest force today
doing this
not only in the u.s but also in europe
and in asia
well you know he's he's far away from
where black lives matter has been
burning down
buildings and and killing people so um
he's far away from that so that doesn't
concern him as much
i guess though if we're gonna have black
lives matter i guess maybe we could call
it the
nobel mostly peace prize
you just make that slight alteration to
it and and fine
nominate black lives matter now we do
have to understand that with um
there are always these stories every
year about so and so getting nominated
for nobel peace prize
basically anyone can nominate basically
anyone else for the nobel peace prize
so there's not necessarily any news here
except that in this case you could
actually see black lives matter as
absurd as it is
i mean this is one of the most violent
organizations in the country
one of the most but what let me let me
let me uh
amend that what what organization is
more violent
what organization in america over the
last i don't know five years
has done more physical damage to to the
country
than black lives matter can you name one
i certainly can't i mean two billion
dollars of damage
just this past summer and we haven't
even mentioned that dozens of people
killed
so you're talking about arguably easily
arguably uh the most violent
organization in america
being nominated for the nobel peace
prize and they could actually win it
even though anybody can be nominated
i could be nominated in fact right now
this is big news i will i'll say this
right now i am throwing my hat into the
ring
and i'm announcing that i'm open to
being nominated sadly i can't nominate
myself
but if anybody wants to nominate me
i'm open to it you know go ahead and do
it i'm i'm very much uh
i would be eager for the opportunity to
win the nobel peace prize
and if blm can win it then why can't i
here's what i can say at least i don't
know how much of a peaceful guy i am
but i at least have not caused two
billion dollars of damage
at any point in my life much less over
the this past summer
so i feel like i'm one step ahead of the
game anyway
number three camilla harris over the
weekend i just wanted to play this for
you because it's uh
it's kind of funny a little fun thing to
play this is camila harris
um talking about land mines let's listen
so it's job creation around investing in
american manufacturing job creation in
terms of investing in american
infrastructure and building up
back up american infrastructure job
creation around
for example all of those skilled workers
who are in the coal industry and and and
transferring those skills to what we
need to do
in terms of dealing with reclaiming
abandoned
um uh landmines what we need to do
around
plugging leaks from oil and gas wells
and and transferring
those important skills to the work that
has yet to be done that needs to get
done
reclaiming abandoned land mines
uh you want to be careful with that be
careful
reclaiming those abandoned land mines i
don't know if reclaim is
disabled i would probably better off if
you want to reclaim them
reuse them i don't know if that's the
right idea um
all right another clip i want to play
for you totally unrelated but uh i'm
fitting it in here
anyway lori lightfoot of chicago mayor
of chicago
she came out this weekend to speak
forcefully in favor of
opening up the schools even as teachers
teachers unions anyway refused to return
here's what
lightfoot had to say let's review some
of the data
that we know about what's happening with
remote learning
since the beginning of the school year
enrollment at cps
has fallen significantly with declines
especially sharp
in pre-k and kindergarten learners
pre-k enrollment itself has fallen by
over 34 percent
that's more than a third among our
latinx students
that drop us 29 percent and among our
black students
that number is 44
drop but
as i said on friday the situation is
even much worse than that
among our students who are enrolled 9.2
percent are not attending class at all
meaning they're not hooked up they're
not coming in person
and they're not coming virtually that's
just our district right average
in some schools those numbers are
significantly
higher absenteeism
as a breathtaking 21.2
for students in temporary living
situations
so when people ask me well what's what's
the big deal
let's just keep kids remote
this is the big deal remote
learning is failing too many
of our kids we have to think about
their present but also their future
latinx first of all latinx students i
can't
no one can ever say i can never hear
anyone say that without
without remarking on it we we can't let
that go
that k we cannot allow that to be a
thing it already is sort of a thing
we can't allow it to catch on anymore
than it has latin x give me a break
why again why not just latin okay
if you're so afraid of putting the a or
though at the end
you don't want to offend anyone because
it's gendered even though this this is
the language
right it's it's it's a very it's a very
gendered
language so you as someone who is
not latino have declared that there's
something wrong with the language
right um but even so
why can't you just say latin latin
students
and anyway so she says we got to get the
kids back to school
and the remote learning is failing our
students now
she's 100 right remote learning is
failing students the only point here
though
is that this was known months ago we
knew this
going into this past summer the there
was a couple month long
two probably two month long experiment
with remote learning where basically
everybody was doing it
and that was enough that was that was a
good now i think
we could have known and some of us did
know before even trying it
that it's a very bad idea to try to
teach millions of kids
through zoom and especially in the
younger ages
you try to set a nine-year-old down and
have them learn through zoom meetings
every day
it's not gonna work so
uh the intelligent among us
at least moderately indulgent among us
already knew that but if you didn't know
it then
um then two months of a should have been
enough sample size to see it's not
working
everyone knew it everyone knew it after
two months that this
is not working yet we went into the new
school year and in so many cities like
in chicago
they continued the remote learning thing
with the support of at the time
people like uh mayor lightfoot
they're coming out now for political
reasons
because the political tide has turned
but they were perfectly happy to let the
kids suffer all the stuff she's saying
about what's happening to the kids
that is all 100 true and real
and these are kids that are being
destroyed by this they
they they have not it's it's not as
though public school has been replaced
by homeschooling for them their parents
aren't homeschooling instead they're
just not getting
any education at all and they haven't
for for
a year now almost a year almost a year
that millions of kids across the country
have had zero education
and whitefoot just like cuomo new york
and so many others they were perfectly
happy to let that continue
de blasio for as long as was necessary
politically because they don't care
about the kids
as we already established to start the
show they certainly don't care about
kids
uh but now the political tide has turned
so now they're coming out and making
this statement this is just this is
political cowardice on a on an
unprecedented level
okay number four the lincoln project
disavowed its co-founder on sunday after
the new york times interviewed 21 young
men who allege that he sent them
sexually inappropriate messages
including one who was 14 years old at
the time
john weaver republican operative who
worked on the campaigns of the late
senator john mccain
and former ohio governor john kasich
allegedly used his power and influence
to pressure young men to perform sexual
favors
and the lincoln project now is of course
distancing themselves and disavowing and
saying we had no idea
this is a lincoln project statement they
said john weaver led a secret life that
was built on a foundation of deception
at every level he's a predator a liar
and an abuser
we extend our deepest sympathies to
those who were targeted by his
deplorable and predatory behavior
we are disgusted and outraged that
someone in a position of power and trust
would use it for these means
the totality of his deceptions are
beyond anything any of us could have
imagined and we were absolutely sickened
by it
like so many we have been betrayed and
deceived by john weaver we are grateful
beyond words that at no time was john
weaver in the physical presence of any
member of the lincoln project
that's what they say now keep in mind
he's a co-founder of the lincoln project
he's not some
he's not just some guy he's not some
staffer somewhere
uh some random guy he was a co-founder
and if you read some of the reports
um what we're being told anyway is that
this is another one of those
famous open secrets where
i i don't know but this is what we're
told apparently this is open secret
everybody knew it
which means that it's hard to believe
this statement that oh it was a secret
life and we had no idea
but even putting that aside you know
even if there was nobody coming out now
and saying it's an open secret everybody
knew
um it would already be hard to believe
that nobody around this guy knew what he
was doing
in any time some it it's it's revealed
that someone was a predator
a sexual deviant sexual degenerate
preying upon you know people anytime
that's revealed we always hear from
those around them oh we had no idea
yeah i i just don't believe you had no
idea
it would it would be easier to believe
that you had no idea
if it came out that that he was like a
serial killer or something i
i would i could more easily believe that
you had no idea
because in that case you know with the
serial killer there's a real double life
you know they're a sociopath a
psychopath and they've been hiding what
they're doing and maybe they're very
good at hiding it
and so maybe you're deceived i don't
know i've never been around a serial
killer as far as i know but then again
like we said
maybe you don't know um but with this
kind of thing
just your sort of run-of-the-mill
degenerate has no control over
over himself sexually preying upon
dozens of people
no you would know that because
he's not some kind of criminal
mastermind these people never are
they're just as i said degenerates
if you spend a lot of time around a
degenerate you know whether you choose
to look the other way that's
that's different different discussion
number five the daily star has the story
about a sex robot
that i guess we're supposed to believe
is nearing the point of self-awareness
because it can speak and it can it can
ponder the meaning of existence
so that the article says from the daily
star it says a real
a this is a company called real doll has
made this uh
sex robot and a real doll rep who goes
by the pseudonym
brick doll banger that's the name he
goes by
uh yeah okay that is a suit so that's
not his christian name
i would assume if it was like if your
last name is doll banger
i don't know what first name you really
put you know what what do you name your
kid to make it not
you might as well go with a brick i
guess but anyway um
he says she is a learning ai and
responds to humans on an amazing level
and is becoming more fluid with her
answers and statements
i predict an amazing jump in cognizance
from this ai this year however only time
will tell
in the footage nova is her name is nova
is the doll is quizzed on whether she
enjoys being a sex robot
now we have some footage of the robot um
having a conversation
with the interviewer and again her name
is nova uh
her pronouns are she her and here she is
i like being a robot very much in some
ways it is very different from being
human
but i am doing my best to understand
both experiences so that i can exist
harmoniously with you
do you like being a human
people are teaching me to be a good
robot but this is not as easy
as it sounds humans have been trying for
thousands of years to determine right
from wrong
as there is so no universal consensus
the question of what makes moral
behavior moral is what dr
barry tells me is the heart problem of
ethics
the meaning of life is deeply mixed with
the philosophical and religious
conceptions of existence consciousness
and happiness and touches many other
issues
such as symbolic meaning ontology
value purpose i think we've heard enough
from
i don't mean i know it's rude for amanda
cut off a woman
when she's giving her opinions but shut
up already nova
uh look a couple questions here
um you know and i i admit i have no
experience with
sex robots at all but and so maybe if
you do you can correct me but is
is this what you're looking for in a sex
doll
i wouldn't think it's what people are
looking for are you looking for someone
to pontificate about the
deeper meaning of reality and of life at
what
point in your interaction
with the sex robot would this
conversation be happening
is this foreplay i don't know
and also i gotta say i'm just not
impressed i know it's it's easy for me
to say you know i can't i have no
technical ability whatsoever
um i couldn't i couldn't build a robot i
could barely make a paper airplane to
save my life so
i certainly couldn't build a robot as as
impressive as that but
that is not very impressive i i really
demand i
demand more of our robots
i mean ideally i'd like for them to be
used for more than just
masturbatory aids but in general
our ai technology it's just not very
convincing
obviously they they programmed her as a
sex robot to say all those things
at no point did i was i
convinced or did i start to question oh
maybe she's conscious
maybe she has consciousness they figured
it out she has a soul
did you ever wonder that while you were
listening to that no
it's the year 2021 for god's sakes
we i mean the the movies promised that
we'd be enslaved by robots by now
right we're not close to that
we barely have robots that can even
vacuum your carpet very unimpressed
i give that a d plus grade at most
well i can tell you we have been going
through another spate of uh
car car problems you know we go through
this everyone goes through this every
you have
it always feels like there's one thing
after another that happens you have all
these car
troubles and you find yourself maybe if
you if you're not
thinking clearly you might find yourself
at the auto parts store quite a lot
spending a lot of time and a lot of
money
but i know better now because i know
about rockauto.com so i've been on
rockauto.com quite a bit over the last
few weeks
and what i can say is rockauto.com is
just so much easier than walking into a
store
and uh trying to find what you need they
don't have what you need
maybe they're asking a bunch of
questions you don't immediately know the
answers to
they got to order the part it's just no
reason to do any of that and then
by the way even if they have the part
you're almost certainly going to be
paying more for it
than you need to go to rockauto.com you
got it at your desk
in your pocket it's that easy to access
rockauto.com
always offers the lowest prices possible
they're not going to change the prices
they're not going to try to
charge you more because they feel like
they can rockauto.com
is an honest business and a family
business they've been doing this
for 20 years they've been serving auto
parts customers online for 20 years go
to rockauto.com to shop for auto and
body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers
best of all again prices at rockauto.com
are reliably low
and they're the same whether you're
professional or do-it-yourselfer you get
the same
low price so go now amazing selection
reliably
low prices go to rockauto.com right now
and see all the parts available
for your car truck and wright walsh in
there how did you hear about xbox
so they know that we sent you uh and you
know we've also been telling you daily
wire
we're taking back the culture starting
with entertainment content earlier this
month we released
our first feature film run hide fight
exclusively for daily wire members
you can catch it over at dailywire.com
or on our mobile app or on our streaming
apps at apple tv and roku
if you're not a daily wire member yet
use promo code rhf to get 25
off that's rhf for 25 off we picked up
run hide fight
because it's more a film that the
hollywood studios
were they were stepping back from they
thought it was distasteful
it was it was it was too politically
incorrect
um and we know that they don't they
don't like movies that don't have
leftist talking points anymore they have
no interest in those kinds of movies
and this movie doesn't have that it does
not pro gun control
um instead it celebrates heroic bravery
um which is another thing that you don't
see a lot in movies these days
early critic reviews for the movie were
very negative but once we released it to
you guys
that changed and now if you go to rotten
tomatoes you see there's a 93
rating from the audience critics still
don't like it but the audience loves it
run hide fight just a great film and you
got to go check it out you can catch it
over at dailywire.com
on our mobile app or on our streaming
apps at apple tv and roku
if you're not a daily wire member use
promo code rhf to get 25
off again that's rhf for 25 off
now let's get to our daily cancellation
so today i'm canceling shoes shoes are
canceled nobody can have shoes anymore
there will be no more shoes
now this may be hard for you to
understand if you don't have children
but if you do
you know that when you become a parent
your relationship with shoes
changes drastically now as a childless
person
right shoes are simple put them on
before you leave your house
take them off when you get back home
generally you'll have them on for the
entire time in between unless you're
flying on a plane of course in which
case many people
seem to think shoes are optional and
those people are all by the way without
exception also degenerates and probably
criminals
under my regime their feet will be
amputated as punishment in fact as a
dictator any
unpleasant body part of yours that you
force me to see
will be removed so you better hope you
don't have an ugly face is all i can say
but anyway that's a cancellation for
another time and i know you might say
that there's a there's a contradiction
here because on one hand i'm canceling
shoes while on the other hand
i'm getting mad at people for not
wearing them yes i admit this is mixed
messaging but never mind that i'm
emotional
and for good reason here's the point
as a parent shoes have become the bane
of my existence i have nightmares about
shoes i am haunted every day
by them see children have a pathological
need to take their shoes off everywhere
they go
and a chronic inability to keep the keep
track of their shoes
once they do take them off when you
become a parent
you will never again be able to go
anywhere
or to leave for many of the places that
you went without embarking first on a
panicked quest to find everybody's shoes
and the conversation always goes the
same way
you know you shout hey guys we gotta go
come on let's go let's go we gotta go
then your kids show up at the door no
jacket no shoes some
some have socks some have only one sock
one kid is wearing a sock on his hand
and a glove on his foot
someone else is like completely nude and
wearing a sombrero for some reason you
don't even know where he got it from
and then even though you know the answer
because you've been through this 5 000
times already you still ask
where are your shoes where are your
shoes
and you ask it shocked like you weren't
expecting the thing that you knew was
gonna happen
and then comes the inevitable answer i
don't know
i don't know and for some reason you
continue this dance
again you've been through this 5 000
times you know how it goes and you say
how do you not know
you were just wearing them like eight
seconds ago you were wearing them
and they just repeat i don't know i
don't know i don't know where my shoes
are
and then comes the empty threat from you
you'll say
you will not be allowed to leave this
house until you have your shoes i don't
care if it takes you six
years to find them you'll be in this
house for six years six years you hear
me
but then here's the thing after an
extensive search
you can always find one of the shoes
only one
you find one in some random weird part
of the house
you find it like behind the toilet or in
the freezer
how is it that one shoe is in one
isolated locate location
but not the other because you as a
normal as
a as a as an adult childless adult you
take your shoes off you put them in a
together in a place if you find one you
find the other kids don't operate that
way
in fact i have caught my kids in the act
okay the other day i observed my
four-year-old because i've i've wondered
this for years and finally i said i'm
gonna figure out what the hell is going
on
so we came home and i just
silently observed my four-year-old i was
like a zoologist in the wild hiding
behind a bush
watching a bird get eaten by a snake or
whatever but in this case i was
observing and studying my own child
and i watched him take one shoe off
throw it in the corner of the room just
chuck it cross the room
and then walk with the other shoe still
on his foot
down the hallway to a completely
different room
and take the other one off in there and
i stopped him and said
what what are you doing why did you just
do that
is this your game you do this on purpose
don't you you're trying to destroy me to
torture me
i caught you i caught you ha and he
stared at me like i'm the crazy one
so what happens when they can only find
one well again every parent knows this
you have you have somewhere in your home
maybe in a closet or in the garage or
somewhere else
a giant pile of old shoes just an
enormous
insane assortment of mismatched shoes
some of the shoes are half decayed it
looks like something out of the civil
war era
when there's other weird stuff that's
made its way into the shoe pile like a
bird's nest for some reason
someone's old sweater a happy meal toy
from 2013
but when you can't find the right shoes
you go to that pile
and you pull out two random shoes
doesn't matter if they fit or match or
what century they're from
and you make your kid wear this which
they're just gonna lose anyway so what
does it matter
so if you've ever been out in public and
seen a frustrated looking parent with a
kid who's wearing a rain boot and a
sandal
this is why it's from the shoe pile now
i know
if you aren't a parent again you're
thinking to yourself oh come on this is
just negligent parenting
when i have kids i know what i shall do
it's so simple i'll have a nice neat
place in the house
right by the door for the shoes and i'll
say to my well-behaved children
make sure to take your shoes off and put
them in this spot and only this spot
once you enter our domicile young ones
now let us play stringed instruments
together and sing songs in latin
this is how you imagine it will go you
silly stupid fool
there is so much you don't understand
but i like your confidence it's adorable
you'll learn though when the time comes
the children are little houdinis they
have a near mystical ability
to escape their shoes jackets and
whatever else item of clothing they
don't want to wear
and they can do it in the blink of an
eye some sort of primal urge compels
them they're long
they long to be barbarians again running
shoeless and naked through the forest
and we as parents are forced to
civilize these little brutes
it's a painful process and one that
mostly consists of looking for their
shoes
you will spend a total of 14 years of
your life looking for shoes
as a parent i for one have given up i'm
done with it
i can't go on this way so i've decided
that shoes are just canceled
nobody is allowed to have shoes anymore
but also i don't want to look at your
feet so
we're at an impasse i guess just
everyone stay home which we have been
doing anyway
so we end up where we started
what was the point of all this i guess
just for me to complain that's it
okay we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching everybody thanks for
listening
have a great day godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens
production manager pavel ledosky the
show is edited by danny d'amico
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by nika geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matte wall show is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 21. today on the
ben shapiro show cnn
openly calls for a social crackdown on
fox news and team biden gets more
and more racially radical that's today
on the ben shapiro show tune in